now tonight for mass mandates joe
biden's disjointed covet 19 policy has
been an utter train wreck one reason for
the adam shift show as i call it joe
biden does whatever dr anthony fauci
tells him to do sadly fauci we now know
is dishonest corrupt self-interested a
government doctor god complex cares more
about his own personal fame and
celebrity status in democratic circles
than he does in protecting the country
in order to get air time on tv he
frequently just makes things up he
guesses he jumps to conclusions he has
been wrong on almost every single major
issue in this pandemic from day one he
flat out lied about the origins of covet
19. we have the evidence and proof his
involvement in gain of function research
at the
woohon institute of virology is now well
chronicled but according to the great dr
fauci he can do no wrong because he is
the very embodiment
of truth and science take a look
anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct
anti-science
flavor to this
so if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people can
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because i represent
science that's dangerous
okay mr science texas senator ted cruz
rightly along with rand paul calling on
fauci to be investigated over his ties
to the wuhan institute of virology
senator cruz joins us now with more
senator you laid out the perfect uh
proof positive that he's lying he knew
about gain and function he knew that the
nih contributed money to it and he lied
tell us tell us the quran well i got to
say
you know dr fauci i think is the most
dangerous bureaucrat in the history of
the country uh you know he talked a
moment ago
you just played about
hurting science i don't think anyone has
heard science has hurt the credibility
of the cdc has hurt the credibility of
doctors more than dr fauci because
throughout this pandemic he's been
dishonest he's been political he's been
partisan and and the american people
know it the the why is it that the biden
administration decreed that that masks
have to be worn in schools by kids well
because teachers union bosses wanted it
and that's not a scientific reason that
is a data reason and you know this
weekend he did this long interview where
he gave the answer he said i represent
science i am science i gotta admit sean
i was laughing it's it's like louis xiv
uh the the the sun king in in in france
saying lesta
it is this delusion of grandeur that you
cannot criticize him and and it was very
striking
you know in the course of that interview
he was asked about i asked the attorney
general merrick garland if he's going to
investigate and and prosecute dr fauci
for lying to congress and and margaret
brennan asked him about that and what
did fauci do he didn't discuss any of
the substance instead he just attacked
and engaged in ad hominem attacks he
basically did the beavis and butthead
defense he just screamed liars at
everything but you know facts are
stubborn things sean and so here are the
simple facts
that fauci needs to explain and the
department of justice should investigate
so on may 11th
fauci testified before a senate
committee that quote
the nih has not ever
and does not now fund gain of function
research in the wuhan institute of
virology that's a clear categorical
statement
but then on october 20th the nih wrote
that they funded an experiment at the
wuhan lab
testing quote
if spike proteins from naturally
occurring
bat coronaviruses circulating in china
were capable
of binding to the human ace2 receptor
in a mouse model
that is gain of function research that
is
taking an existing virus and modifying
it to make it more dangerous to humans
and and
listen at the end of the day
18 usc section 1001 makes it a felony
punishable by up to five years in prison
for lying to congress the statements
from dr fauci and the nih are directly
contradictory and i got to say i think
margaret brandon is a talented
journalist but she dropped the ball and
not following up letting him just
respond with insults instead of asking
him the simple question you stated that
we don't fund gain of function research
the nih stated we do fund gain of
function research they can't both be
true
and if you lied to congress it's a
felony she didn't press him on that and
the reason this matters
is is there is a lot of circumstantial
evidence to suggest
that the u.s government participated in
funding research
modifying coronaviruses that could well
have led to covid19 and if that's true
that is stunning and indefensible we
know the chinese government has enormous
culpability but there's a real
possibility the american government
under dr fauci does as well and that's
what he doesn't want to address i i i
think you're right as his testimony i
think it was may 11th and the the
letter from the nih on on october 20th
are directly contradictory hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else